big hat there's always something to
discuss in the world of the nfl
well there's always something to discuss
in the world of the pittsburgh steelers
i think is the appropriate way to say it
because they have single-handedly given
us an entire offseason of story lines to
keep us ready to go up until the combine
they basically have been the stop gap
between you know le'veon bell and
antonio brown and now these james
harrison comments to help us get to the
combine and get to the draft and get to
the 2019 nfl season and of all the
former steelers that would have become
renegades in the media against the
steelers james harrison i guess on one
hand you would say he's the most likely
on the other hand you'd say he's the
least likely because he hated the media
he didn't want cameras around he didn't
want to interact but also he seems like
the kind of guy who would love to just
turn everything upside down and that's
what he's at least trying to do he has
comments about the steelers and
specifically he puts the blame on the
head coach the head guy has to be the
one that takes charge i believe it's
fault on even with my situation it's
fault on me it's fault on tomlin's fault
on the team it's got to this point
because tommen has allowed a certain
amount of things to go on and rather
players take advantage of that or step
beyond that it's got to a point where
it's so far out that now he can't rein
it back in so to speak and i hate to say
this
but he's right
because everything about antonio brown
oh
look this guy came in as a six-round
pick this guy didn't come in as the
sixth overall pick he was allowed to
morph into a diva he was not a diva when
he walked through the door so somebody
ultimately tomlin allowed him to be late
allowed him to live off campus and and
not with his teammates when they were at
training camp allows him to breeze into
the locker room when everybody else is
in their uniform and he's just showing
up and there's no consequence he he is
smitten by what he can do on the field
so he's never stood up to him and he's
allowed it to be this way and and and
that mentality i think has created the
the situation that the steelers now deal
with where there's different rules for
different guys and the dysfunction has
completely taken over
the different rules for different guys
also if you read the harrison uh what he
said i think the important part was the
big ben
portion of his quotes he said for me ben
being the unquestioned leader i have no
problem with that situation other than
the fact that no one is beyond
unquestioned
and how many times do we hear stories
about bill belichick treating tom brady
just like one of the other 52 guys
you know reaming him out in in tape in
film ringing him out on the sideline
making sure that he is as focused and as
ready as everyone else on the team and
the leadership does come from the top
it's usually the coach it's usually the
quarterback and if the coach treats the
quarterback differently you will
immediately get resentment from everyone
else on the team from guys who think
they're just as skilled from guys who
are getting paid just as much from guys
who think think they are just as
important to the steelers success and
then that's where it all kind of falls
apart that's where the antonio brown
thing i'm not i'm not excusing antonio
brown for kind of being all over the
place the last year but it makes sense
when you can't have that quarterback
coach
relationship that everyone can look to
and say okay this if the quarterback has
a bad game the coach is going to hold
him accountable not hold everyone else
accountable and let him kind of slide
and i think you've seen it through
through tweets and and statements from
antonio brown that the steelers treat
big ben differently than everyone else
and that starts the resentment in that
locker room and has a lot of guys saying
i want money and i want to be out of
here
best example of the point you made when
chad johnson was traded from cincinnati
to new england this was after the
lockout in 2011 so there was a plenty
plenty of stuff had gone on from the
super bowl from the playoffs until
everybody gets together for the first
time no off season program they're all
gathering and chad johnson's in his
first meeting with the patriots and the
first thing belichick does he puts up
film of the playoff loss to the jets
from the prior year and destroys brady
in front of everyone and scares the crap
out of chad johnson in the process
that's what belichick does that's what
you do no one is above the team and it's
not just tomlin as it relates to
roethlisberger big cat it was the gm
earlier this week that had this long
monologue about how big ben can do
whatever he wants and they should listen
to him and he can call me out if he
wants to and that tells me that the
problem doesn't end with tomlin it goes
higher than tomlin the gm the owner
where are these folks in the
organization that could say to tomlin we
can't have this or that could say
themselves go into the locker room and
say hey guys this is the way it's going
to be if tomlin's not going to do it so
i think there are plenty of people who
have blame for what's happened in
pittsburgh and and i think the fans are
starting to slowly wake up to it that
something significant has to change at
the top of the organization before the
team is ever going to be as good as it
can be
so what is this going to look like for
2019 because that's the interesting part
it feels like
with these quotes with antonio brown's
imminent trade with big ben getting a
year older doesn't it feel like this is
almost
they're all kind of the walking dead
when it comes to what the future of the
steelers look like the future this
dealer is not going to be big ben in
five years the future of steelers is
probably not gonna be mike tomlin in two
years so what does that look like do
they you know if they if they get back
to the playoffs but fall short again do
they put it all back together and try to
do it yet again in 2020 i i it's just a
weird situation because
it was it was kind of contaminated just
to uh your quarantine sorry to just
le'veon bell to start the season now it
feels like it's spread everywhere now it
feels like everyone's pointing fingers
and everyone's kind of blaming everyone
else and there's just
it doesn't seem like a team that can put
it back together
and play football next year
one thing i've learned living in and
around pittsburgh most of my life when
the ho the bar is high for the steelers
they find a way not to meet it but when
the bar is low that's when all of a
sudden they blow it out and they end up
having a great season so maybe this is
good for the steelers that that all of
this stuff is dragging down the
perception of what they're going to be
and maybe they find a way to rally
around it maybe they fix it just for one
year and they end up being far better
than we expect them to be even without
le'veon bell and antonio brown but you
do feel like this is all coming to an
end that something big has to happen and
you mentioned that mike tomlin may not
be there in two years the one and i made
this point before uh as as this
dysfunction really began to unfold in
the offseason the steelers seem to put
too much of their identity in the fact
that they've only had three coaches for
50 years like that's this weird point of
pride like hey we've only had three
coaches for 50 years well you know what
maybe there's a point where your coach
has to think i can get fired i think
every football coach has to believe that
there is a way that the facts will
unfold that results in the ultimate
accountability landing on me and me not
having a job and if that is taken off
the table in pittsburgh because they
like being able to say we've only had
three coaches in 50 years then your
coach is never going to feel that
tom coughlin's best two years with the
giants were two years he was on the hot
seat they won the super bowl both years
sometimes it's good to be on the hot
seat and i think that until the
organization is ready to hold coaches
accountable and be ready to fire coaches
you're not going to get possibly the
best performance or you're going to
allow this kind of malaise and this
complacency that leads to dysfunction
that's a great point because you know a
lot of organizations go too far where
everyone is always you know working for
their job or fighting for their job and
then you get the infighting but the
steelers are the other the other side of
the uh you know the pendulum swing here
where mike tomlin why would he change
what what incentive does he have to
change
if he knows that he's going to have his
job pretty much no matter what and now i
should also say that the steelers
still have an unbelievably talented
roster and
at the end of the year last year they
were one of the hottest teams i think
they were one of those teams where
everyone was looking at if they can get
away into the playoffs here they're
playing some good football they went
down to new orleans they were that juju
smith shuster fumble away from possibly
winning that game you just saw that
highlight but you're absolutely right if
if the coach doesn't feel like he
is on the hot seat ever not even a mild
knee just hit the seat warmer you know
hit the two out of three on the seat
warmer just so he can feel like a little
bit pressures there
why would he change and why would he do
anything differently why would he
deviate from what he's already done you
see offensive coordinators get fired
defensive coordinators get fired mike
tomlin survives it all and this is going
to happen again this year and i think
these kind of comments from james
harrison like those matter those that
will matter for the locker room like
that's something that he's almost saying
out loud what probably is whispered
around the pittsburgh steelers locker
room and now it's been said out loud and
i think guys will probably talk about it
and they'll say you know what it is kind
of it is kind of uh you know
a problem here that big ben gets
different rules than the rest of us or
that le'veon bell can sit out the whole
year and
le'veon belton going back to it real
quick
the thing that shocked me with that was
how many of his offensive linemen call
them out too you never see that in the
in the nfl the offensive linemen really
rarely speak to the media and they
really don't call out guys and it's a
unit that's very cohesive and that tells
you that there is it's just going all
all different directions in pittsburgh
there's there's people pointing fingers
everywhere everyone's blaming everyone
else and it's just it's crazy like i
said to start the show
thank you to the pittsburgh steelers
because you have given us enough drama
to carry uh nfl off-season shows before
the combine and draft
and let me tell you i remember thinking
when the offensive lineman were calling
him out that that's not something
they're doing on their own they're
hearing that in the meeting room they're
hearing that from mike tomlin and
ultimately the steelers it's like the
steelers had this weird disconnect where
they didn't realize the reason le'veon
bell isn't signing a long-term contract
is because the steelers refuse to
structure the contracts the way other
teams do and they don't give the guys
the security right out of the gates that
other teams will give a guy and and so
le'veon bell to his credit stood up and
said i'm not doing it and i'm not taking
your 14 and a half million i'm forcing
my way to the market because that's the
only way i'm ever going to get the kind
of long-term contract i deserve because
you guys refuse to give a contract like
that to anyone other than your
quarterback ben roethlisberger and i
guess it all comes back to the fact that
they put roethlisberger on a plane above
everyone else and it's all blown up on
the steelers and and now you know the
beneficiary is antonio brown big cat
because you've got the gm of the
steelers trying to argue that oh we'll
find a way you know we want significant
compensation we're just not going to
give him away well you know what if you
don't give him away he's going to keep
poking the bear he's going to keep
causing more dysfunction and you're
going to wish you had gotten rid of him
and i think at some point they will take
the best offer they can get because they
just need to start peeling away some of
this crap so they can focus on
rebuilding this thing
yeah antonio brown has been very
effective in uh convincing the world
that he's kind of a free agent of sorts
like i don't even
you know he he's had the meetings he's
like we're we've agreed that we're going
to trade me and it's so weird it's such
a bizarre situation i've never seen a
trade be talked about as much as this
trade without it having actually
happened and it you know it still can't
happen for a couple weeks and i don't
know
i mean at what point is he
really hurting the value of their trade
partners i mean are the steelers going
to be able to walk around the nfl and
say hey
this guy we want a first round pick or
whatever they may end up wanting because
everyone knows he wants out and everyone
knows that they've met the r that rooney
and antonio brown have met and they've
decided to trade him it feels like this
is that he's kind of undermining me they
it would be interesting to see if the
steelers then
go back in antonio brown and say you
know what we're going to trade you to a
place that you don't want to go we're
going to trade you to buffalo we're
going to trade you somewhere he wants to
go to the 49ers he wants to go to the
patriots he wants to go to the chiefs he
wants to go to all these winning teams
but what if we trade you someplace that
you don't want to be and and you can go
deal with it and see if you're happy
there
but who's going to trade for him if they
know he doesn't want to be there that's
the thing no one's going to want to
inherit the antonio brown that's trying
to blast his way out of pittsburgh and
this guy's either a genius right and
he's playing this the perfect way to get
what he wants or you know i've mentioned
from time to time this week and i don't
say this completely facetiously because
if the guy's got something going on he
needs to get it figured out but at times
in this offseason he's he's reminded me
of that that weird period where charlie
sheen was in his tiger blood phase and
like something's not right here not
quite to that extreme but at times i
just wonder like
is he doing this deliberately or can he
just not help himself but either way i
think it makes it harder to trade him
because you have to give the stealer
something that makes them happy you have
to make antonio brown happy you're
taking a lot of risk here that he can
still play at a high level and is this
all going to work and can we throw it
all together in a matter of weeks and i
think it makes it harder to trade him
and it gets them to a point where maybe
they just have to cut him loose at some
point or take whatever low round draft
pick they can get
you're right he needs one friend in his
group to be like you know what antonio
let's maybe go to the gym today and not
tweet let's not do instagram today let's
not do uh you know 10 questions with
antonio brown uh so that it will always
lead to me bashing big ben let's put
down the phone let's go enjoy you know
the the beach or wherever he may be
living right now i think he's out in
california let's do that instead of
tweeting all of my thoughts as soon as
they pop in my head
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports